Then we'll actually implement a fast compact primitive that operates on a single block of data.
Recall that a compact inputs a true or false flag for
every thread and a value for every thread, and outputs only those values which the input flags as true.
So, in this problem, the strategy that we will do this scan is as follows.
For step 1, within each warp, we will sum up the number of true flags.
For step 2, we will do an exclusive sum scan of the per warp results.
For step 3, we will do a exclusive sum scan of each warp, with the
starting value of each warp equal to the corresponding output in step 2.
For step 4, we will use the resulting address as scatter address into the
output array for each thread for which the flag is true and we will scatter the value into the output array.
As an example, consider the following, where we
used a warp of size 4 to make the example easy to understand.
And here's our input of 4 warps of 4 flags each.
Step 1, I'll put 2241. Step 2, I'll put 0248. Step 3, I'll put 0112, 2233, 4567, 8999.
And step 4 scatters the underlined elements to the following flags.
And that's that, and I will follow them up with programming questions.